some groups just don't get along
every day billions of soldiers fight a
merciless war on thousands of fronts and
it's been going on for over 100 million
years
the world war of the ants
[Music]
and our ancient beings that arose around
160 million years ago and took over a
wide variety of ecological niches so
successfully that they became one of the
dominant animals on planet earth
today they count more than 16 000
different species with over ten thousand
trillion individuals
collectively ants alone make up twenty
percent of the entire animal biomass on
land
similar to humans their recipe for
success is
collaboration while a single ant is
pretty useless together they are able to
achieve stunning feats
they construct complex colonies care for
livestock pursue agriculture or have
complex symbiotic relationships
and of course ants wage war
even among the same species a constant
state of conflict is pretty common
skirmishes raids and full-on invasions
are happening every day causing millions
of casualties
let's look at some of the most
interesting ones in a series of videos
in this one the army ant a swarm made
for war
the army ant group consists of about 200
different species
army ants do not build nests they live a
sort of nomadic lifestyle with groups of
millions of individuals on a hunt some
species form large columns up to 100
meters long
killing and immediately dismembering
every insect or small vertebrate they
encounter
the biggest hunting parties can kill up
to 500 000 animals per day
some army ants specialize in hunting and
consuming other social insects like
termites wasps and especially other ants
wasps are fierce and may seem
invulnerable but if a swarm makes its
way to their colonies they don't even
stand a chance
the much bigger and stronger wasps might
kill a few of them but they are quickly
overwhelmed even if their queen survives
an attack the army ants steal the
colonies larvae and quickly devour them
there is no recovery from that
when army ants discover another ant
colony they immediately attack
now you might think this would be a more
even battle but it's not
because army ants act as a social unit
they are especially dangerous and
effective
most army ants are not particularly
impressive individually but they can
overwhelm their victims with sheer
numbers before the victim colony can
mount an effective defense
and so invasions tend to be won by the
attackers and the prey colony is damaged
significantly or is exterminated
interestingly army ants don't fight army
ants
when two swarms encounter each other in
the wild they either pass through each
other ignoring the other swarm or both
colonies just move away
which makes sense from an evolutionary
standpoint
army ants that fought other army ants
probably eradicated themselves millions
of years ago indeed they're so deadly
that other ant species had to specialize
to survive their presence
many species just panic and evacuate
their nest when they notice army and
scouts carrying as many larvae with them
as they can in order to return and
rebuild after the attack
other species have invented living
bunkers since fighting is so futile
they have worker classes that have big
square heads
when army ants show up they use them to
block the entrances to their nests so
the attackers have to give up after a
while
but not everybody is afraid of army ants
leafcutter ants form some of the largest
and most complex societies of any animal
other than humans
they live in extensive nests many metres
deep and across harboring millions of
citizens with a highly sophisticated
division of labour
like huge soldiers 100 times more
massive than a worker their sole purpose
might be to defend their colonies
against army ants
they still have a nemesis though
the diet of the army ant species pneumo
murmix as in becky eye consists mostly
of the larvae of other ants compared to
other army ants they have a more robust
soldier cast
so far they are the only known species
that can successfully attack a mature
colony of leaf cutters
when they find a leaf cutter colony
hundreds of thousands attack in a long
column
the moment the leafcutter ants notice
the army and attack they go into crisis
mode and immediately alert their
soldiers who very quickly swarm to the
site of attack
a line develops that can be a few meters
wide and up to a meter deep
the leaf cutter soldiers go head to head
with the army ants locking on them and
try to cut through their heads
smaller leaf cutter workers help by
grabbing the enemies
small teams carry out attacks behind the
front line where they dismember their
enemies by ripping their legs from their
bodies
the attackers meanwhile try to swarm
their victims soldiers and sting them to
death in a mob
despite the powerful defense and the
determined response the army ants are
still superior in numbers
so without knowing if the battle can be
won the leaf cutters prepare for the
worst
workers rush to create barricades and
seal off as many entrances to their nest
as possible to secure their brood
if the leaf cutters are not able to
repel the invaders or at least barricade
enough of their entrances in time the
army ants swarm the nest overrunning all
opposition
they penetrate deep into the hidden
chambers and steal tens of thousands of
the leaf cutters brewed to eat them
even if the leafcutter colony survives
this is a heavy blow
regardless who's won the war thousands
lay slain on the battlefields
when the army ants attack
death follows them
but there are other species that form
much more dangerous ant armies species
that form super colonies covering
thousands of square kilometers over
multiple continents engaging in wars
kilometers across
they deserve their own video though
no matter the scale war is a part of ant
existence be it between huge colonies or
small groups trying to fend off a raid
in tropical rainforests but also in the
cracks of the concrete we walk over
every day
humans have decided that war is not a
thing that they want to do a lot anymore
for ants though the other ant will
always be the enemy
no
some groups just don't get along
if you can't get enough events we're
developing part two of the ant series
right now with the support of curiosity
stream
curiosity stream is a subscription
streaming service with thousands of
documentaries and non-fiction titles
quotes out viewers can visit
curiositystream.com to get a free 31-day
trial to watch films like big world in a
small garden a documentary that takes a
close look at the world of insects
around us
or other documentaries by the likes of
stephen hawking david attenborough and
many more all available for offline
viewing
once your trial is over the subscription
is only 2.99 per month
curiosity stream was founded by the same
people who started the discovery channel
with documentaries spanning science
nature history technology and lifestyle
it's a great way to binge watch fun
videos while accidentally learning
things
thank you so much to our friends at
curiositystream for supporting our end
succession and making ambitious projects
like this possible
stay tuned for part two and visit
curiositystream.com
for your free trial
[Music]